[Music]
foreign
good morning everybody Donald Trump's
son-in-law has told this program the
former president is obviously thinking
about running for the White House again
in his only British broadcast interview
Jared Kushner told me that Mr Trump
hates what's happening with America and
they had discussed another campaign for
2024. his comments come as President
Biden warns that American democracy is
under assault from election deniers and
political violence Donald Trump says
he'll pardon and apologize to those who
stormed the capital on the 6th of
January last year I began by asking
Jared Kushner what he thought of the
2020 election result
President Biden is is the president
right now so there is a transfer of
power
um I think it was a very sloppy election
I think it's caused a lot of people in
our country to look at how our elections
are conducted you know during covid they
changed a lot of the rules which gave a
lot of people a lot of concerns with how
our elections are conducted but the hope
is is that you know in in the next
elections which are coming up you know
we'll have much uh cleaner elections and
it'll give people a lot more confidence
in terms of in terms of what the outcome
is yeah but some still say it was stolen
by the Democrats what do you think I
think they changed a lot of rules at the
last minute use covet as a pretense to
uh to uh to to to to to fight the
election so you think it was stolen I
think it was a very sloppy election in
terms of how it was conducted and I
think that Joe Biden's the president I
think that's been a disaster for our
country and for the world
um okay let me just quote a couple of
things to you seven in ten people say
Biden was legitimately elected according
to the Washington Post uh the Trump's
own attorney general Bill Barr said we
have not seen fraud on the scale that
could have affected a different outcome
in the election the Associated Press
saying there were fewer than 500 cases
of voter fraud so why are they all wrong
I'm not saying they're wrong or right
but what I will say again if you go into
my book you go through uh 2016 right
president Trump wins the election and
then you have the Washington Post the AP
or the science sources you just cited
basically covering for two years
hyperventilating that he colluded with
Russia and it was an illegitimate
election right so again one thing I
learned in in my life is you have to
find your own truths you have to look at
the details and the facts yourself and I
think that that's why I thought it was
very important to write this book right
the Trump administration had I think
some incredible successes when you think
about historic trade deals historic
peace deals unemployment was at a low
inflation was low wages were rising in
America we were very strong we had a
peaceful world and those things didn't
happen by accident got it uh Republicans
some right-wing Republicans continuing
to challenge the result you decided that
the best place for you to be was in the
Middle East with the Abraham Accords
talisman
so the Abraham Accords was the biggest
peace deal in the Middle East maybe in
the last 50 years and what happened
there was we got Israel and the Arab
countries to start working together to
change the arab-israeli conflict I spent
my first year listening to a lot of
people who'd worked on the file who were
in the region the leaders there I take
people into those discussions and I kind
of found my own truth and I thought that
maybe the conventional wisdom was wrong
and then for three years we were
attacked for doing it the wrong way not
like the experts experts before me and
ultimately we made that breakthrough
which turned out to be a tremendous uh
relief of tension how comfortable were
you being in the presence of the de
facto leader of Saudi Arabia very
comfortable some people have issues
about the murder of Jamal khashoggi and
his involvement in that did that play on
your mind at all that was obviously a
significant uh consideration I I wrote
about in the book it was a it was an
episode but did you ever bring it up
with him yeah I write about the
interactions we had on it but look our
job was to represent America's interest
in the region to that end do you think
MBS could expect support from any future
Trump Administration I think it will
always be based on the policies I think
the media always tries to yes
no I I think it's going to be policy by
policy considered you know the media
always tries to say you're in one camp
or another and what I try to show in the
book is that we were incredibly nuanced
in the policies bad guys you know no
again I sometimes you deserve it and
sometimes maybe not but but what I find
is that if you go through the Trump
Administration and again I think that
you'll see there's a lot of very
rational policies that were pursued and
I think that that gets lost sometimes in
the hyperventilation or the uh or the
sensationalism of the media the 6th of
January it was very much a date in
history what were your recollection of
events on that day so I was on a plane
back that day again I think that nobody
in the White House thought there would
be violence as far as I was aware
oh boy and obviously what happened was
terrible seeing people storm I got back
I obviously you know I ended up getting
to the White House after a statement had
put out and then after that we worked
continuously to try to make sure there
was a peaceful transfer of power okay so
talk me through events on the day
very simple I testified to the Gen 6
committee voluntarily when they called
landed in a plane a secret service told
me to go to the home instead of to the
office which I was happy to do I'd
worked for about 72 hours straight you
know getting this deal done that I was
just telling you about uh get home about
jump into a shower get a call from Kevin
McCarthy saying we got a real problem
here at the Capitol anything to do to
help would be appreciated so obviously
put a suit on run to the White House at
that point a statement had been out and
uh you know and you know there was
nothing more that seemed that could be
done so we put our focus on the next day
how do we make sure messaging gets
Tighter and how do we make sure we're
doing everything and in in the month
leading up to that I've been working
with Jake Sullivan on transitioning all
the Middle East files he was up to speed
on that stay the 6th of January if I may
um what did you say to the president
uh I saw him after it was done so okay
so you didn't see him at all that day I
saw him after it was done he'd gone up
[Music]
How concerned were you given that you
were such a you know a high profile
member of the team How concerned were
you about the safety of Vice President
Pence
like I said at the time I wasn't aware
of the details of what was going on but
I was concerned for the safety of
everybody obviously okay go it's just
again I actually was also not working at
the time but apparently there was some
suggestions that is his at some point
his life was was in danger that's not
something that that you were aware of uh
look I think the Secret Service does a
tremendous job I have a lot of
confidence they you know protected him
they protected the president they
protected our family and a lot of our
officials for uh many years I don't know
how close or how not close it came that
day but like I said ultimately they
restored uh peace there uh I'll tell you
over five years there was over 600 Trump
rallies we never had any violence never
had any problems and um and again it was
unfortunate what happened that day
people are very interested in in your
life with with Ivanka and in the book
you talk about how your marriage almost
didn't happen tell my viewers why that
was we were both coming up in in New
York at the time we were in different
businesses but uh but we had concerns
about religion some concerns about how
we wanted to live our lives but
ultimately our love is is very strong
and we found ways to to work through a
lot of those issues and it was uh Billy
Joel who got you back together with your
Uptown Girl is that right he was there
that weekend but it was really we were
there together Wendy Murdock did a great
job of getting us in a situation where
we were together and I think when we
were on a boat in the south of France
yeah neither of you expected the other
one to be there no we were both kind of
uh duped into being there by a very uh a
very uh well-intended Matchmaker okay
well they were obviously very successful
you went to see uh president Trump your
future father-in-law to tell him that
you wanted to propose
and he said yes but by the time you went
to propose he'd already told him I
didn't find that out till later so I I
go through the The Proposal in the book
and actually I took my wife to a
Broadway show that night and uh Broadway
shows always start on time like
clockwork for whatever reason that one
was delayed uh my brother was in my
apartment uh an aster place you know
with candles and Bros and I was just
nervous that the whole place would burn
down and and so we got there I was very
very nervous but luckily she said yes
and it's been an amazing journey
together ever since yeah
um you didn't
tell him that you had thyroid cancer did
you why not I didn't I ultimately did
tell him but I didn't want to burden him
he had so many things on his mind again
I I it's hard to imagine what it's like
being the leader of the Free World but
there's just a lot on your shoulders I
write a funny scene in the book where
before I'm about to disappear for a
couple days to get it the surgery done I
get called to the Oval Office he closed
the door which he never did he was
always a very you know open uh president
and he says you know are you nervous
about the surgery
and I said well how do you know about
that and he says well I'm the president
I know everything so I clearly found out
I think one of the White House docs had
told him and he says you know don't
worry about it we got your back here
take a couple days off from work and uh
whatever you need from us we got you so
he was very very sweet about it and uh
but I just didn't want to burden him
with it and have you been poorly again
recently you've had further surgery yes
I recently went for a checkup they found
something that required another surgery
I went and did it and thankfully that
was successful as well that's so told so
how are you now how do you feel I feel
good yeah thank God yeah again medicine
today is incredible and uh you know I I
just feel very blessed that there's
amazing doctors who do the great work
they do um how do relax
I love working you know again I always
feel like work is a it's like Puzzles
right so I I don't mind working non-stop
and then uh you know now that I moved to
Miami for four years I wasn't able to
spend time with my kids but I've been
developing different hobbies that I'm
able to do with them so like I started
making them breakfast every morning
which I love what do they like uh
pancakes I'm very good and Waffles uh
they're there I've done very well what's
the technique uh the technique is we
have like a high protein
a batter you try to make sure you whip
it up pretty good but you know getting
it just right and I think it's nice and
fluffy yeah as long as you get chocolate
chips in it you know kind of forgives
any cooking lessons so it's good and
then also taking the kids out boating
I've been learning how to do that and
fishing and you know a lot of different
outdoor sports that you can do in Miami
that you don't do in New York so it's
been a lot of fun your children Arabella
Joseph and Theodore did they know that
Grandad was the leader of the Free World
they knew he was president but they knew
that he was Granddad and they knew that
he had a big supply of chocolate so
anytime they they showed up at the
office they knew they could run in there
they'd get a kiss and uh and a bag of uh
Hershey Kisses oh fantastic um Arabella
Versace poetry in Mandarin to Chinese
president XI didn't she at Mar-A-Lago
[Music]
at marylago quickly if I may um piece
shattered there very tranquil pace for
the family peace Shattered by an FBI
raid why did the president take home
toxic top secret documents uh you have
to ask him uh that question but you know
what I will say is if you look at my
book you'll see that he was under a
constant attack but he took top secret
documents home but potentially risking
the security of the United States yeah I
think that it's something that again
this seems like it's an issue of
paperwork that should have been able to
be worked out between doj and him I
don't know what he took or what he
didn't take but I think right now we're
relying on leaks to the media which is
the same thing haven't we where it says
top secret
yeah like I said I I I I've seen a lot
of allegations made by the media over my
four years that turned out not to be
true so I think that this whole thing is
actually elevated so the fact that we've
seen photographs that say top secret
document we should wait and see whether
or not they were even though we're being
told by the FBI uh that they were yeah
like I said I go into my book the
accusations that were made of trump uh
not just if you could answer that
question yeah I mean first of all he was
the president United States he had the
highest clearance in the world so I
don't know if the like this may be a
paperwork issue this may be I I don't
know like I said I haven't been involved
in the details of it okay talk to me
about 2024 would you like to uh when
might he decide whether he's going to
run or not
you know nobody can speak for him have
you spoken to him about it uh he's asked
me about it I said You Know It's Tricky
what did he ask you uh I'd rather not go
into that but but basically I know that
he's um he's obviously thinking about it
he hates seeing what's happening in the
country you know he had the economy
running so well he filled the whole
economically that was caused by covid he
got us out of it with the vaccine but
and when will he decide when will he
have to decide we're heading towards the
midterms aren't we so he's going to have
to decide soon when he's ready I I I
like not really out there is he I'm
sorry he's not ruling it out like I said
with Trump it's hard to rule anything
out so he's uh he's a very flexible
thinker yeah would you like to be part
of a trump Administration
um the answer is yes isn't it no the
answer is is that you know right now my
mind is is really enjoying the private
sector I think that again I don't
believe that people should be career
political people I think that it's an
amazing honor to be able to go and serve
your country if he rang up and said you
know what Jared I'm going to run again
and I'd like you to be part of my
Administration you couldn't say no to
him yeah I think the difference between
a next time potentially and last time is
now he has so many qualified people who
are around who are in the administration
family though
uh yeah but it's uh but but there's a
lot of great people now and so my hope
would be that uh that with some of those
great people they'll be able to play
roles and I'll be able to you know
support them in any way he's definitely
going to run his name
like I said with him you never know so
it's uh he keeps it interesting all the
time Jerry because you know it's been a
pleasure thank you very much indeed for
joining us thank you for having me thank
you thank you
you can see that interview in full for
at 9 30 on the breakfast show this
morning right now though let's bring in
Martha who's standing by in La for his
height Martha fascinating staff huh
it really was fascinating and you
conclude there with the question which
is looming large over American politics
and National discourse and that is of
course will Donald Trump run again in
2024 Jared Kushner not just a close
family member of Donald Trump married of
course to his daughter Ivanka but he was
also at the very heart of the Trump
White House for four years and the fact
that he says he's spoken to his
father-in-law about running in 2024 is
yet another indication that he will do
so and that in itself is a remarkable
State of Affairs given where Trump finds
himself embroiled in a hefty swirl of
legal inquiries not just that FBI raid
of his Mar-A-Lago house in Florida which
you questioned Jared Kushner about
there's also an ongoing civil inquiry
into allegations that Trump and his
family fraudulently inflated the value
of their assets like hotels that's not
to mention the ongoing January the 16th
inquiry which is looking at what if any
role Donald Trump played in instigating
that storming of the capital yet despite
all this he remains by far the most
powerful person on the right side of
American politics
uh indeed and we've been hearing
actually also from President Biden
overnight he obviously is aware of what
president Trump might be doing for 2024
and he's getting involved
yeah Donald Trump was very much front
and center of this Prime Time address
um by President Biden it was an
unflinching and full full-throated
speech by President Biden in the past he
shied away from calling Donald Trump by
name but this time he took the gloves
off and he said that Donald Trump and
his most fervent supporters were
launching an assault on Democracy I
think we can hear a little bit of that
speech now
Donald Trump and the Maggie Republicans
represented extremism that threatens the
very foundations of our Republic the
Republican party today is dominated
driven and intimidated
by Donald Trump and the Maggie
Republicans
and that is a threat to this country
it was an unusual backdrop for that
speech as well a presidential address in
front of the dramatically illuminated
um Philadelphia Independence Hall where
the Constitution was signed as President
Biden
reminded his audience by America's
founding fathers it was there that
President Biden chose to frame the
upcoming November midterm elections as a
battle for the soul of this nation
okay for now thank you and you can watch
as I said my full interview with Jared
Kushner filmed in Miami Beach 9 30 and
then again 11 30 and 1 30 today
highlights and reaction throughout the
program this morning
in other news a full month long Sky News
investigation into the culture in
Westminster has uncovered allegations of
sexual misconduct by a cabinet minister
and a top number 10 aide two women have
given our political correspondent Liz
Bates detailed first-hand accounts of
what they claim happened to them to
protect the alleged victims Sky News has
allowed them to speak anonymously
betrayed and voiced by an actor this is
one of them
I was sexually assaulted by someone
who's now a cabinet minister I was in my
early twenties and didn't really know
how to deal with it I was super drunk
he's feeding me more wine and I'm
already quite obviously tanked but after
a while I was like you know what would
you mind if I just went to bed so I went
to bed but obviously he didn't leave me
alone I woke up the next morning and I
realized what had happened I reported it
to an MP I worked for a couple of years
later and I did go to the police years
later as well and had a very brief chat
with them
and decided not to proceed with a formal
complaint because they couldn't give me
any reassurances until I made a formal
statement
I was too scared to kick-start that
process and risk it spiraling out of
control
well the government said we take
allegations of misconduct extremely
seriously and there are robust
procedures in place to raise concerns or
ministerial appointments also follow
established processes all prospective
government employees are subject to
necessary checks and vetting we do not
comment on individuals there is an
established code of conduct and
complaints procedure where people can
report complaints in confidence we take
any complaint seriously
or you can watch Liz's full report on
the Sky News website or listen to the
full story on the Open Secret podcast by
scanning the QR code on the screen now
John hi by conservative MP and wish you
soon act supporter Kevin hollandrake
hello to Mr hollandrake thanks for
joining us on the program talking about
the leadership race in just a second but
I do want to ask you about that
Westminster culture to start with
um
frightening allegations from those two
young girls
absolutely and they should be fully
investigated if a complaint is made
absolutely
um I don't believe it's cultural but
clearly in a cohort 650 people you're
going to see some poor behavior and it
where that exists it should be and
complaints are made it should be
thoroughly investigated and those people
held to account
but what does it say about the culture
in Westminster when people are too
scared to come forward and make formal
complaints
I don't I don't know if she said she was
too scared to do that she may have done
I I didn't um I didn't get all the
interview
um but if that's the case that is a
concern but the procedures have been
changed changed quite recently so you
can make Anonymous complaints now so you
are protected quite rightly so that
shouldn't be the case
um as I said I don't think it's as
cultural in Westminster but nevertheless
one complaint like this is one complaint
too many it should be if a complaint is
made it should be properly investigated
no just one there is I mean we saw the
Chris pincher stuff as well which seemed
to take forever for people to react
absolutely totally inappropriate and it
should have been tackled earlier and um
and that obviously led to the demise of
the Prime Minister yeah one of the
reasons that she said that we saw the
Prime Minister uh leave office on Monday
of next week one of the other reasons
was what was happening at Downing Street
uh over lockdown um Nadine Doris the
culture secretary has said that the
Privileges committee investigation is a
biased kafka-esque Witch Hunt what do
you think
well I don't agree with everything
Nadine says but I think there's some
legal advice there that I'm sure the
Privileges committee will take into
account I think the key thing is here is
is the word intentionally
um it's not whether the prime minister
or anybody or any other minister misled
Parliament it's where there's an
intention to do that and that's what the
privileged this committee is going to
look at if he decides to go down this
route which I think it is and uh and
then we'll report accordingly yeah
number 10 um number 10 apparently taking
legal advice want to move on to the um
election in just a second but number 10
taking legal advice and they say it
calls into question the legitimacy of
the inquiry
um that is being conducted at the moment
is that something that you think that
the uh the upcoming prime minister
should look more closely into
well I think the committee itself the
committee is an independent Committee of
the hex it's not a governmental issue
the house committee these are elected
members who sit on that committee and
they represent the house as a whole so
they've got an independent job to do
um it's across Party Committee uh I'm
sure they'll take account of the legal
advice that's that's just been uh issued
and um and act accordingly but as I say
the key thing about this his word
intentionally did the Prime Minister
intentionally mislead the house that's
what they should look at and and they
should be allowed to do their job
um your man
um is certainly enjoying quite a balance
uh in the polls in the last few days of
this election race he's left it too late
now hasn't he
said I I don't agree I mean I've seen
some of the polls the national polls
um I think it's quite hard for Paul's to
determine who is a conservative member
who's not because there's none open
database but I know who mine are I
pulled my 700 members
239 of the responders about a third of
them responded and Richie's got an
eight-point lead
um and I've seen similar kind of polls
around different constituencies around
the country so I know these cut and
dried I think he's probably Mecca neck
and uh and we should let this is the
last day we could speculate on this
probably no more after today okay and
we'll know the answer on Monday
lunchtime we certainly will and
hopefully we'll chat to you again next
week for now it's great to talk to you
thank you as always
how are the papers feeling about things
this morning the express going back to
party gate and saying that even one of
Boris Johnson's fiercest critics at the
time now says the whole investigation
was wrong
story is also the lead in The Daily Mail
this morning there you go top lawyers
set to deal devastating blow to PM party
probe the telegraph tells us that GPS
were given at record pay Rises during
the pandemic
On The Run Olivia's killer that's the
lead in the mirror after police released
CCTV of the man they say shot dead
Olivia prattle Olivia Pratt Corbell
forgive me running away after the
shooting in Liverpool
the guardian says that two out of every
three police forces in England and Wales
are experiencing increased gun crime
and the sun reports that while the rest
of us are tightening our belts a group
of Whitehall staff have been treated to
a 50 000 pound boost up aboard an
airplane
still to come on the program for you
this hour getting reaction to my
interview with Jared Kushner from former
White House Aid and now vocal Trump
critic omaressa manigo Newman
also speaking to Republican strategist
and former member of Donald Trump's
presidential transition team that's
Brian Lanza
and talking to the author of a report on
what a trust government will have to do
to meet her pledge to boost defense
spending to three percent of GDP by
2030.
before that though let's take you to
Pakistan the country's South is brazing
for yet more flooding as a surge of
water is Flowing down from the north
meanwhile Health officials have reported
an outbreak of waterboard diseases in
flood hits areas speak to our
correspondent in Pakistan Sima hi Simon
it's it's good to see you this morning
um just how bad is it getting there
okay it is extraordinary every time we
head out to take a look at what's going
on we see yet another breach and more
water flooding areas and people's homes
just before we came to you a tractor
went right past loaded with people's
belongings there seems to be a departure
going on from a village nearby right now
because there must be a warning that yet
another flood barrier has been breached
what little there is in this part of the
world you can probably see behind me
there's a thatched roof that's the all
you can see of the house in the water
here people have resorted to living in
tents on the sides of Roads that's the
people that have the tents overnight
we've heard from the military that are
carrying out a rescue operation that
they have rescued 50 000 people that's
no mean feat when you consider they can
only take 18 people on a boat or 25 in a
helicopter but when you consider more
than 30 million people are affected it's
just scratching the surface we joined a
rescue mission yesterday on a boat it
took us three hours to rescue around 18
people five children seven women a
number of men and you know a lot of
people didn't want to come on the boat
they were terrified either of the water
and of drowning or of leaving their
homes and their belongings they're in an
extraordinary predicament here but I
really can't begin to tell you just how
much water there is three hours on a
boat to get to one family alone okay
okay for now thank you
hello again everybody are you very
welcome to join us on the breakfast show
here on Sky News Friday morning top
stories Donald Trump's son-in-law Jared
Kushner tells me that the former
president is seriously considering
another run for the Wyatt
Joe Biden accuses some of Trump's
supporters of extremism that threatens
America's foundations
Sky News investigation reveals
allegations of sexual misconduct against
a serving cabinet minister and a senior
number 10 aide
more now on our exclusive interview with
Donald Trump's former senior advisor and
son-in-law Jared Kushner Mr Kushner has
told this program the former president
is obviously thinking about running for
the White House again
you know nobody can speak for him have
you spoken to him about it uh he's asked
me about it I said You Know It's Tricky
what did he ask you uh I'd rather not go
into that but but basically I know that
he's um he's obviously thinking about it
he hates seeing what's happening in the
country you know he had the economy
running so well he filled the whole
economically that was caused by covid he
got us out of it with the vaccine but um
when will he decide when will he have to
decide we're heading towards the
midterms aren't we so he's going to have
to decide soon uh when he's ready not
really though is he I'm sorry he's not
ruling it out like I said with Trump
it's hard to rule anything out so he's
uh he's a very flexible thinker
joining us now is the former White House
Aid and now vocal Trump critic Omarosa
manigo Newman hello I'm a Rosa it's good
to see you uh what do you think do you
think he'll run again
um absolutely he's going to attempt to
run again but he has so many legal
challenges that it may be impossible for
him to run again if in fact he is found
or indicted for the crimes that he is
accused of
it did look as though when I was talking
to Jared Kushner that he was backing
away from being involved in any form of
White House Ron uh going forward and
certainly wouldn't work with so closely
with the president again you used to why
did you decide it wasn't right for you
okay first of all I need to apply to you
for that interview with Jared he was
very much
um uncomfortable answering some of the
tough questions but you held his feet to
the fire
um to answer your question
I think that the most interesting thing
about what's happening with Jared's book
tour and what he's telling is what he's
left out of the story he didn't talk
very much about the fact that he made
the decision to not provide mask to
Americans when he was presented with
that option could have saved millions
and millions of people's lives he
mentioned in your interview that there
were some rules changes that affected
Donald Trump's uh possible win for the
White House but they were in charge so
who changed the rules and he also
claimed that he created peace in the
Middle East but there is not peace so
there were a lot of things that you
really presented to him that he was kind
of avoiding answering he he did say the
last election in his words was sloppy
and and referring to what you were
commenting on there Democrats used covid
to change the rules so you you you say
that Republicans were in power and so
they were the ones that were changing
the rules he disagrees
yeah they were in power so I'm not sure
how Biden would have changed the rules
when he was just running and also Jared
need to own his part of the fact that
the Postmaster General actually broke
down sorting machines to keep people
from being able to vote by mail and it
greatly impacted the folks who were not
able to get to the polls so the people
who were making the decisions and
changing the rules were in fact Donald
Trump and he is now being investigated
for his behavior during the election and
him trying to kind of uh Skirt the Rules
and call even officials in Georgia to
ask them to find more votes so that he
could win
um and as you know that's illegal
and the situation in Mar-A-Lago is just
a matter of paperwork says Jared Kushner
even though we have seen images
presented by the FBI that seemed to say
top secret documents
yeah you know um Jared and I both had
the same level of clearance we know that
you cannot handle that level of
sensitivities and documents in a very
careless way and we have to acknowledge
that he was very careless and so that
was a very much needed Ray to get back
the property of the United States
government they are not the property of
Donald Trump and of course Jarrett knows
that and I think that while he's on this
book tour I think he should be honest
and tell the truth about what's
happening and the truth is that Donald
Trump has become unhinged and that he
should not get anywhere near the Oval
Office ever again
um Declassified is what those documents
were according to the president
um could they have been Declassified to
that extent
okay there is no uh rule where you can
just have a broad declassification of
all documents some of those documents
could only be read in Skiffs in these
secure compartmentalized environments
and certainly not in his drawer with you
know passport and other trivial
documents
um and just left out for anyone to read
including members of his golf club so
certainly that's just not true and you
know I think the thing that worries me
the most about Jared's story and him
sharing is that there are some critical
things that he could say that could
actually help with investigations like
January 6. he said that he was in the
shower the riots on January 6 for
several hours long how long was Jared
Kushner in the shower on that day where
he had no idea what was happening so I
think that as he's on this book tour as
you saw in your own interview
um he's avoiding telling the full story
and I was that's what I was hoping he
would do in this book trust me I I tried
a lot but yeah
but he was going nowhere near the sixth
of of January and what about as far as
the 6th of January is concerned
president Trump has said that if he came
into office again he would pardon and
apologize those involved on the day what
do you make of that
let me just comfort you that Donald
Trump will never ever hold office again
because the American people now see the
truth and the truth is that he has
empowered criminals people who have
sought to do harm to our Republic and he
has even said as you stated
unapologetically that he will pardon
many of them and invite them back in to
cause more chaos so it gives me some
comfort to know that the American people
have now seen the truth but I'm also
still very concerned with hearing
interviews like Jared Kushner and
listening to Donald Trump's rhetoric
that he wants to be in power again and
he shouldn't be you say that but you
know it does look as though um President
Biden is a little bit ruffled by the
thought that President Trump could run
again for 2024 and to that end he has
been um face on attacking uh Maga
supporters
yeah because Mega supporters have shown
that they have no respect for the rule
law in fact I don't even think they
respect the constitution of this country
and so uh President Biden could be more
forceful uh certainly he has a whole
campaign team to come up with a strategy
to take on any opponent including if
Donald Trump decided to you know do the
grift again and try to run again but I
think that what's most important right
now is that Biden focused on improving
the economy and trying to combat the
issues such as you know the the fact
that our educational system has declined
during covid and even in Jackson
Mississippi we have historic flooding so
there are some things that he is should
have his attention on right now as
opposed to on the race
Omarosa it's uh so good to see you again
thank you very much indeed for taking
the time and thanks for staying up late
no worries thank you thank you well the
Republican strategist and Trump Ally
Brian Lanza with us now hello to you
Brian it's great to see you thanks for
joining us uh on the program this
morning thanks to you as well for
staying up late for us
um your thoughts first of all on the
suggestions uh by Trump overnight that
he would pardon and apologize to those
involved with the 6th of January riots
if he became president again
yeah first of all good morning thank you
for having me I'm disappointed to hear
that uh I think a lot of those people
you know broke the rules and broke the
laws and uh and yeah and there's
consequences for those actions and uh
and and that they deserve consequences I
don't believe pardoning part being then
being pardoned should be anywhere in the
conversation
and what did you make of Jerry Kushner
telling this program that they have been
discussing together him running for
2024.
yeah obviously the you know the former
president's considering it he's still
very popular within the Republican party
I think people are becoming more and
more nostalgic about his economy as they
suffer through this Biden economy and
and I think it's uh at least for the
Republican party I mean he's he's he's
the front runner there's a tremendous
amount of interest in him running again
and uh and then we'll see how that
shakes out in the general election
against Joe Biden how much support would
he ex could he expect from you
oh through the Republican party I mean
he'll have maximum support I mean he'll
you know it's it's running against Joe
Biden my assumption is he'll probably
have close to 92 percent of the
Republican support behind him
what do you personally think Ryan
you know it's it's yeah I I wish there
was a different standard Bearer uh going
forward I but yeah at the end of the day
he's going to be our party's nominee and
you know he's better than Joe Biden is
the way we sort of look at it from in
the economic numbers I think you know
Joe Biden has done a tremendous amount
of disservice to the American economy he
has weakened our images abroad you just
look at Afghanistan and I think it'd be
a good thing to to remove this president
with a Republican president whether it's
Trump or anybody else
can a president whose home has been
raided by the FBI to find top secret
documents that could put the security of
the United States at risk ever be a
person in office again
I think the voters make that decision
it's certainly not going to be people in
Washington DC much less you know law
enforcement the FBI who Trump he himself
has fought with during his tenure as
president so I think the American voters
gonna have to make the determination if
if the FBI is truthful if it's if
there's charges being brought forward
we'll have to deal with it but it's it's
not going to be some policy maker or
some bureaucrat of Washington DC that
makes a decision it's going to be the
American voters in Iowa in New Hampshire
South Carolina and across the United
States that are they're going to decide
what they're willing to tolerate uh
Jared Kushner referred to the documents
that the FBI say are top secret they
provided photographs they say to back
that up Gerald Kushner says it's just an
issue of paperwork what do you think
yeah it's it's I would say this it's an
issue of paperwork for a president
former president but it's a big deal for
somebody like me and I've been caught
with any of those documents I'd be you
know I'd be arrested I'd be prosecuted
to the fullest extent of the law but our
laws are a little bit different than how
they treat American presidents and I
think that's the problem in the media uh
that they're they're giving the belief
that uh all from a presidency are
treated the same with respect to their
documents foreign presidents have wide
latitude with their documents and
that'll get sorted out by the justice
department and his lawyers but at the
end of the day uh it's it's it's not
going to be anything that prevents the
president uh former president Trump from
running what's your experience of Jared
Kushner
I had a positive experience I've worked
with him closely during the campaign I I
worked with him when he was in when
President Trump was in office uh I have
a positive working experience for
charity that I always found him to be
you know empowering whenever there's a
complex problem he always he always
empowered people to look and find those
Solutions on the campaign in the
government and I think that's the type
of the leader you want somebody who
empowers uh their people to find
Solutions and uh and to move forward
and how important do you think he would
be to any future
um president Trump he did give me the
impression talking to him that he had no
interest in returning as a senior aide
but how important do you think it would
be for Trump to have somebody like him
as his right hand man again
you know I I think it's critical but I
think the president is showing time
after time I mean he's 70 something
years old he's worked with uh with many
people throughout his lifetime and who
continue to work uh with more and more
people but uh there will be a loss not
having Jared there if we make it back
and uh and you know Jared's moved on to
very you know to better and brighter
things you know he's got this book
that's now New York Times bestseller
list you know he has his his fund that
he's that he's working very hard for
it's it's hard to move backwards
yeah and you're completely content as
far as that fund is is concerned
obviously it is originally funded uh by
the Saudi uh government fund
they fund a lot of funds I mean it's
it's it's it's what the international
business Community looks like they go to
where people are spending the money and
it's just right happens right now that
the Middle East is spending a lot of
money that doesn't bother me or the
American people
but you're very happy um Brian if it was
President Trump 2024.
you know it's
if he's our nominee we're 100 behind
them uh you will do everything we can
for him to be Joe Biden I think it's
time for some fresh you know faces in
the Republican party to emerge but uh I
don't think it's going to work out that
way and that's just the way politics
works out sometimes sometimes the the
Next Generation has to wait a little bit
longer great to talk to you thank you so
much for taking the time and again for
staying up late for us thank you thank
you
our interview in full with Jared Kushner
at 9 30 this morning you can catch it
again at 11 30 and 1 30 and if you are
on the hoof today you can see it on our
mobile mobile devices as well mobile I
said I was only in America 24 hours uh
other news were you a man has been
detained after he reportedly aimed a
handgun at Point Blank ranged towards
Argentinian vice president Christina
Fernandez de Kushner Argentinian
president Alberto Fernandez said the man
pulled the trigger but the gun did not
fire Mr Fernandez called the incident a
homicide attempt
a man accused of being a member of the
Islamic Terror cell known as The Beatles
is due to appear in court today earlier
this month Amy Davis originally from
West London was arrested at Luton
Airport after being deported from Turkey
he's charged with possession of a
firearm for Terror purposes and two
charges relating to funding terrorism
a 326 pound cost of living payments
expected to help more than a million
households when it's rolled out today is
the first of two government payments to
help those claiming tax credits cope
with soaring gas and electricity costs
but the union the TUC reckons it won't
even scratch the surface with average
annual energy bills expected to hit
three and a half thousand pounds next
month
while the promised buyers trust to spend
three percent of national income on
defense would cost an extra 150 billion
pounds over the next eight years that's
according to the rusi think tank so
let's get more should we deputy director
general of rusi Professor Malcolm
Chalmers is with us now hello to you
Professor it's great to see you thanks
so much indeed for joining us on the
program
um this morning so Liz trust is saying
um she would spend at least three
percent that may have to go even higher
depending uh on where we find ourselves
with Russia in the coming uh months and
indeed years uh give us an idea if you
would uh given the report an idea of the
scale of the increase that you think is
needed
well this trust in her campaign has been
very clear that she is committed to
spending three percent of our national
income and defense by the end of the
decade by 2030 and right now we spend
just over two percent of our national
income and defense so over that period
uh if the economy continues to grow at
the rates projected we're talking about
a 60 increase in defense spending over
the next eight years after allowing for
inflation that's a big chunk of money
and what the report spells out is is
that we need to do quite a lot of
Preparatory work in the next two or
three years if we're to spend that money
efficiently and effectively by the end
of the decade uh since uh spending money
is one thing spending it effectively is
another and of course the purpose of
this trust is commitment is to ensure
that as a country we've got
significantly more defensive ability see
in eight years time than we have now the
amount of money is very substantial is
approximately one percent of our total
national income so
you've also got to spell out the
government will have to spell out how
it's going to pay for that whether by
cutting other areas of public spending
or indeed by raising taxation it's of
course part of that broader question
about what the spending priorities of
the incoming Administration will be yeah
and to that end I mean let me just make
it clear to viewers what it might mean
to them 5p in the pound increase in both
the standard and high rates of income
tax by 2030 or an increase in the
standard rate of v80 from 20 to 25
percent
um if the government doesn't do that and
doesn't find the funds what's the flip
side
well I think if you don't raise their
funds for spending more in defense from
taxation then you will have to find the
savings elsewhere in the government
budget whether it's in international
spending and Aid spending or indeed a
tackling climate change or in in welfare
spending or in health or education in
the end that sometimes if there's a
temporary demand and government
resources borrowing may make sense in
this case we're talking about our
long-term sustained increase they've
been spending one particular area in the
lottery of that is the money has to come
from spending cuts or tax Rises I think
one important part of the historical
context here is that really for the 70
years since the 1950s we've been able to
fund increases in the share of national
income spent on health uh by reducing
the share of national income going to
defense what's often called the peace
dividend and that's meant even though we
spend so much more on health and social
care and pensions than we did in the
past and we haven't had to increase
taxes that much to to pay for that
because defense has been coming down it
defends is now going to rise as the
proportion of national income then it
raises much wider questions about Are We
Now prepared to make the sacrifices in
terms of other public services are
indeed in terms of Taxation to pay for
it okay it's good to talk to you this
morning thanks for taking the time much
appreciated
lighter story to end the hour for you
one of the world's oldest zoos is
preparing to close its doors after 186
years and move to a new site because of
the impact of the pandemic Bristol Zoo
Gardens has occupied the site as I said
for 186 years let's get more should we
Dan is there for us this morning hi Dan
good morning
um flamingos I'm guessing in the
background I always thought they were
pink flamingos
they are pink if you look close enough
okay
um yeah 90 million people have gone
through the doors here at Bristol Zoo in
its 186 year history and tomorrow
Saturday will be its last day open to
the public the zoo is actually moving to
a new site in a couple of years let's
chat to Brian Zimmerman who is the head
of conservation and science here at
Bristol Zoo Brian just tell us I know a
lot of zoos faced a real pressure during
covid what's the reason Bristol Zoo is
is closing its doors it's one of the
oldest zoos in the world
um well the reason we're closing is
because we have another Zoo called wild
place and it's 12 times the size of this
zoo and so we can do a lot more in terms
of conservation and improvements from
welfare of the animals so there's more
space for the animals more opportunities
to do conservation
um and it'll just be overall a much
better experience this is going to turn
into housing a lot of this land here
isn't it there was a lot of economic
pressure during the pandemic on you guys
and also yes uh every Zoo had a
difficulties during that time because
we're very much dependent on visitor
numbers to help fund our operations so
when we couldn't have visitors come
through the door that was a big
challenge for us
in its 186 year history I was reading
that some people used to come to the zoo
and ride Rosie the elephant Zeus have
obviously transformed but what is the
place of zoosing in modern society
because a lot of people say look after
186 years it's time to to not have these
these caged animals and and not have
zoos of course on top of that you've got
conservation and allowing people to
learn about the animals it's a difficult
balance it is but I think zoos actually
have a bigger role to play in modern
society than ever before because we're
in the middle of a major major
biodiversity crisis and zoos have a role
to play in conserving some of the most
threatened species on the planet through
our breeding programs in some species
that don't even exist in the wild
anymore and without zoos they would be
gone forever how do you you've got lines
here you've got grass you've got the
flamingos here I mean what happens are
you taking these animals from the wild
how are zoos working these days yeah
none of the animals come from the wild
they're all part of breeding programs so
they're well managed on a European and a
regional basis and the animals are bred
in the zoos and they're adapted to
living in zoos
um and just quickly tell us about the
new place obviously this is coming
turning into housing here but it's it's
12 times the size isn't it and fewer
animals yeah that's right we want to
give more space to the animals that
we're sticking with um those that are of
conservation significance for us so
having 12 times the space and 150 acres
allows us to develop state-of-the-art
exhibits and and enclosures for the
animals okay fantastic really appreciate
you chatting to us Brian and there's a
lot of events taking place throughout
the day here they've actually opened the
doors early here at the zoo because the
demand has been absolutely huge in the
last couple of days a lot of people
wanting to come it's been a lot of
people part of a lot of people's
childhoods here in Bristol but it will
be closing its doors uh tomorrow the
final visitors after 186 years
okay thanks very much indeed thank you
and you know I've got those useless
facts every now and again apparently
flamingos are pink because of the fact
that they eat shrimp actual fact coming
up kind of coming up in just a few
moments time what does Jared Kushner
think about Donald Trump and 2024 stay
tuned and find out
[Music]